Now let's move on to numerical summarizations. These are some of
my favorite. These are the summarizations you're going to want to use when your
boss says, "show me the numbers". These are the numbers you're
going to want to show your boss. And,
what kind of numerical summarizations? Well,
we've talked about it a bit already. We might want to do
a word or record count. And for a word or record count,
which is something you've already done with the web server log
files, the [UNKNOWN] just outputs the thing you're interested as the key,
and outputs one for the value. The reducer then chugs along, sums up the values,
bada bing, bada boom, problem solved. This is like the Hello World of map
produce. Slightly more difficult are things like
calculating the mean or the median, or
if we really want to get really fancy, the standard deviation of a set of data.